hi I'm John Stamos I play dr. Nikki on
the hit Netflix show you and I came down
here to to answer or read some thirst
tweets I wanted to do the the bit with
the puppies but I got stuck with this
[Music]
uncle Jessie from Full House was 110
percent my first love that's very sweet
I thought these were supposed to be like
John Stamos is the hottest man on earth
I'd let him scrub my face against hot
asphalt if it meant I could even be in
his presence why would I you could be in
my presence I'm not that difficult I'm
very approachable just come around you
see me in a restaurant
hey John I was the girl I wanted you to
put my face in asphalt I wished John
Stamos was my therapist on you I don't
know if you do I found that most in my
research most therapists are more puffs
than their actual feeling their patients
and I think dr. McKee is what the hell
kind of witchcraft is John Stamos doing
this Batman is just like eternally
beautiful
Loretta Stamos my mother thanks mom
y'all John Stamos age is like a fine
wine he only gets better with age you
are Netflix I drink the blood of Lori
Loughlin
that's my secret these are two nice I
watched Milo Ventimiglia if you could
pronounce the name he said he would have
sex with you I can't just had a salad so
beautiful delicious and Greek that I
called it John Stamos it's nice right oh
no three just toss my salad
you ever watch full house reruns no John
Stamos comes on and it's just
aggressively good-looking question mark
coverage Bob Saget okay shout out John
Stamos for being the only person to ever
look hot with a mullet I mean come on
Uncle Jesse cut it out there were a lot
of great lesbian mullets in the 80s mine
was not the best no I don't I don't
think I've ever Gordon I don't know why
I grew up back then that's the thing the
other girls said you ever watch the
reruns no because I look at my god I'm
like what was he thinking it's like a
crow died on my head or something
John Stamos wasn't your first crush
you're lying and if you didn't think he
was still hot in fuller house you're
lying again
who would lie about who would even say
those things he wasn't my first crush
liar there's a lot of other people that
could have been someone's first crush
Farrah Fawcett and that Farrah Fawcett
poster where she was okay you guys would
she go bathing suit with the nipples
currently in the market for a sugar
daddy requirements 401k okay willing to
hook up your bank account to my
Starbucks card cool must be John Stamos
I mean my religion when I was 11 was the
way John Stamos said have mercy anything
Catholicism died over that actually I
shouldn't say this but people are always
so nice on these do you have any dirtier
ones alright John Stamos is so powerful
how is it at any age I want him to break
my back like the seal on a water bottle
[Music]
[Music]